I want to look at a clip of our friend
Walter Masterson Walter Masterson went
to
uh CPAC and he did some really
interesting interviews and this is one
that is uniquely stupid in a way
this is a a trump supporter that Walter
interviewed and one of the things Walter
does at these events is he pretends to
be on their side like I think here he's
wearing an ultra Maga shirt and you know
he pretends to be on their side and one
of the things that happens with these
folks when you pretend to be on their
site is you can get him to agree to
almost anything because they don't
really have any actual beliefs that they
truly understand they just want to feel
correct here is a trump supporter who
says she is against critical race Theory
but she wants more black history to be
taught of course ignoring the reality
that what they call critical race Theory
often is just teaching black history
take a look at this gold mine when I get
very aggravated because I notice the
folks who push CRT do not seem to take
the time to teach about Frederick
Douglass who was a great black founding
father they have erased the work of
early black people in this country
Frederick Douglass well you know what
when they want to teach that they're
accused of teaching critical race Theory
um uh Harriet Tubman many of these
things were not taught about them and
they're full uh capacity so what we need
to do is we need to get rid of the CRT
nonsense and start teaching more about
what Harriet Tubman Frederick Douglass
John Brown the person who uh stole the
Confederate ship W.E.B DuBois Marcus
Garvey yeah Malcolm X Martin Luther King
yeah Farrakhan I mean you know the the
list oh that's great she's nodding about
Farrakhan she has no clue who some of
these people are you all you all can
tell I'm sure that's crazy it is a
robbery uh of both black and white
children to not teach that history
because black children should be knowing
that there were great black leaders that
they can identify with and uh yeah it's
like no one none of these kids know who
Marcus Garvey is yeah exactly
this this is this is really really
stunning stuff and it's stunning for a
number of different reasons
um this is very similar to
I hate Obamacare oh okay what about the
Affordable Care Act that's fine right
but they're the exact same thing this is
very similar to get the government the
hell out of my medicare don't touch it
oh but Medicare is a government Health
Care Program this is slightly different
but still similar to Sharia law is bad
and we've got to keep it out of the
United States when it's Muslim Sharia
law but a Christian version of that
Sharia law would actually be fine
because the founding fathers were
Christian or whatever the case may be
this really is something else and this
is part of why there's no talking these
people out of these beliefs really scary
stuff very nice job by Walter Masterson
there I've had such trouble finding a
great razor where I am not cutting
myself or getting those Nicks on my skin
which are so common with the cheap
disposable razors you have to meet our
sponsor Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below